We have already introduced the
concept of the conditional PMF
of a random variable, X, given
an event A. We will now
consider the case where we
condition on the value of
another random variable Y. That
is, we let A be the event
that some other random variable,
Y, takes on a
specific value, little y.
In this case, we're talking
about a conditional
probability of the
form shown here.
The conditional probability--
that X takes on a specific
value, given that the random
variable Y takes on another
specific value.
And we use this notation to
indicate those conditional
probabilities.
As usual, the subscripts
indicate the situation that
we're dealing with.
That is, we're dealing with the
distribution of the random
variable X and we're
conditioning on values of the
other random variable, Y.
Using the definition now of
conditional probabilities this
can be written as the
probability that both events
happen divided by the
probability of the
conditioning event.
We can turn this expression
into PMF notation.
And this leads us to
this definition
of conditional PMFs.
The conditional PMF is defined
to be the ratio
of the joint PMF--
this is the probability
that we have here--
by the corresponding
marginal PMF.
And this is the probability
that we have here.
Now, remember that conditional
probabilities are only defined
when the conditioning event has
a positive probability,
when this denominator
is positive.
Similarly, the conditional PMF
will only be defined for those
little y that have positive
probability of occurring.
Now, the conditional PMF is a
function of two arguments,
little x and little y.
But the best way of thinking
about the conditional PMF is
that we fix the value, little
y, and then view this
expression here as
a function of x.
As a function of x, it gives
us the probabilities of the
different x's that may occur in
the conditional universe.
And these probabilities must,
of course, sum to 1.
Again, we're keeping y fixed.
We live in a conditional
universe where y takes on a
specific value.
And here we have the
probabilities of the different
x's in that universe.
And these sum to 1.
Note that if we change the value
of little y, we will, of
course, get a different
conditional PMF for the random
variable X. So what we're really
dealing with in this
instance is that we have a
family of conditional PMFs,
one conditional PMF for every
possible value of little y.
And for every possible value
of little y, we have a
legitimate PMF who's
values add to 1.
Let's look at an example.
Consider the joint PMF
given in this table.
Let us condition on the event
that Y is equal to 2, which
corresponds to this row
in the diagram.
We need to know the value of the
marginal at this point, so
we start by calculating the
probability of Y at value 2.
And this is found by adding
the entries in
this row of the table.
And we find that this
is 5 over 20.
Then we can start calculating
entries of
the conditional PMF.
So for example, the probability
that X takes on
the value of 1 given that Y
takes the value of 2, it is
going to be this entry, which
is 0, divided by 5/20, which
gives us 0.
We can find the next entry, the
probability of X taking
the value of 2, given that Y
takes the value of 2 will be
this entry, 1/20 divided
by 5/20.
So it's going to be 1/5.
And we can continue with
the other two entries.
And we can actually even plot
the result once we're done.
And what we have is that at 1,
we have a probability of 0.
At 2, we have a probability
of 1/5.
At 3, we have a probability
of 3/20 divided
5/20, which is 3/5.
And at 4, we have, again,
a probability of 1/5.
So what we have plotted here
is the conditional PMF.
It's a PMF in the variable x,
where x ranges over the
possible values, but where we
have fixed the value of y to
be equal to 2.
Now, we could have found this
conditional PMF even faster
without doing any divisions
by following the intuitive
argument that we have
used before.
We live in this conditional
universe.
We have conditioned on
Y being equal to 2.
The conditional probabilities
will have the same proportions
as the original probabilities,
except that they needed to be
scaled so that they add to 1.
So they should be in the
proportions of 0, 1, 3, 1.
And for these to add to 1, we
need to put everywhere a
denominator of 5.
So the proportions are indeed
0, 1, 3, and 1.
Pictorially, the conditional PMF
has the same form as the
corresponding slice of the joint
PMF, except, again, that
the entries of that slice are
renormalized so that the
entries add to 1.
And finally, an observation--
we can take the definition of
the conditional PMF and turn
it around by moving the
denominator to the other side
and obtain a formula, which
is a version of the
multiplication rule.
The probability that X takes a
value little x and Y takes a
value little y is the product
or the probability that Y
takes this particular value
times the conditional
probability that X takes on the
particular value little x,
given that Y takes on the
particular value little y.
We also have a symmetrical
relationship if we interchange
the roles of X and Y. As we
discussed earlier in this
course, the multiplication rule
can be used to specify
probability models.
One way of modeling two
random variables is by
specifying the joint PMF.
But we now have an alternative,
indirect, way
using the multiplication rule.
We can first specify the
distribution of Y and then
specify the conditional
PMF of X for any given
value of little y.
And this completely determines
the joint PMF, and so we have
a full probability model.
We can also provide similar
definitions of conditional
PMFs for the case where we're
dealing with more than two
random variables.
In this case, notation is
pretty self-explanatory.
By looking at this expression
here, you can probably guess
that this stands for the
probability that random
variable X takes on a specific
value, conditional on the
random variables Y and
Z taking on some
other specific values.
Using the definition of
conditional probabilities,
this is the probability that all
events happen divided by
the probability of the
conditioning event, which, in
our case, is the event that Y
takes on a specific value and
simultaneously, Z takes another
specific value.
In PMF notation, this is the
ratio of the joint PMF of the
three random variables together,
divided by the joint
PMF of the two random variables
Y and Z. As another
example, we could have an
expression like this, which,
again, stands for the
probability that these two
random variables take on
specific values, conditional
on this random variable taking
on another value.
Finally, we can have versions of
the multiplication rule for
the case where we're
dealing with more
than two random variables.
Recall the usual multiplication
rule.
For three events happening
simultaneously, let's apply
this multiplication rule for the
case where the event, A,
stands for the event that the
random variable X takes on a
specific value.
Let B be the event that Y takes
on a specific value, and
C be the event that the random
variable Z takes
on a specific value.
Then we can take this relation,
the multiplication
rule, and translate it
into PMF notation.
The probability that all three
events happen is equal to the
product of the probability that
the first event happens.
Then we have the conditional
probability that the second
event happens given that the
first happened, times the
conditional probability that
the third event happens--
this one-- given that the first
two events have happened.